welcome to another one of my doctor said
they're trying to talk videos and this
one I'm responding to a question that I
got the year really great question has
to do with nitty-gritty one count and
ethical approach I think is a good
question i asked for any moral theory
that is worth how can I practice virtue
ethics day to day so what concrete
things what's her program can i put in
place if i bought into this this moral
theory virtue ethics and there's a lot
of different variants but broadly
speaking if I've accepted that this is a
good thing what do I need to do to
actually make it work and I've come up
with a bunch of different ideas under
forming headings these are not an
exhaustive list of possible things you
can do and they do reinforce each other
or connect up with each other if you
read classic virtue ethicists like
play-doh or Aristotle or August mean
Thomas Aquinas say that's all even at
the theatres to a certain extent it
could be considered diversity analysis
then you're going to see a lot of this
kind of advice being being talked about
maybe not quite so explicitly but I
think it's all good ideas so I divided
into four different areas there's
practice you know what do you actually
do to build up virtues within your
material lysis self-examination i
abbreviated self-exam just
word this category models which is very
important for virtue ethics and then key
ideas and actually i think i would like
to dance he critical about prevailing so
let's actually start with key ideas
virtue ethics is a more or less
systematic way of approaching rural life
and decision-making development judging
between right and wrong with a bad even
circumstance other values like you know
the noble of the base and there are
certain key ideas and i put the word
delagua here epictetus actually uses
that word and i think it's a good thing
to think about oftentimes the dog was as
bad things but in ancient philosophy
what a dog was you know it's got used in
religious context afterwards is
something that you need to believe
something that you need to accept
something that you need to buy into if
you want to make progress so if for
example you want to do certain schools
of sociology there's certain basic dog
knows that you have to accept and if
you're going to stay at the very
beginning i'm not going to accept those
well then you can't do that kind of
thing or you know if you want to
certain literary criticism let's say
it's psychoanalytically based and you
have to buy in some things that are
coming from psychoanalysis you don't buy
any of them well you're not going to do
that sort of thing so it works that way
with virtue ethics as well you know I
would say one of the key ideas is you
have to actually buy into the notion
that you are just some degree
responsible for your character if you if
you think that you're not you just can't
do virtue ethics you also can't be a
relativist in any real sense of the
virtue of this is you can't say it's all
just a matter of opinion you know Plato
about this Nietzsche face this and I
think this Jerry Springer things that
table or you you actually have to be
committed to the idea that some ways of
life are better than others or fully
human are realizing what's within us
better or the flourishing more more
often and some ways of life are less
likely to do that that's something you'd
have to my aunt there's a lot of key
ideas even getting down to in a level of
what is Temperance or what is justice
that once you've got a hold of them and
once you understand them understanding
them is itself you know kind of an
achievement then you want to hold on
them so you want to reinforce those you
want to think about those damned if de
you don't want to just learn it once and
then let it all slide or imagine it's
going to stick with you yeah so I think
that along with that goes you have to
study it yet each day I'm not saying
that you necessarily have to carry
Aristotle's [ __ ] McCain
around your back pocket and pop it open
every so often but I think that if you
want to make progress in virtue ethics
you probably want to do some study every
day this doesn't necessarily have to be
reading from the primary texts I mean
you could read a summary of Aristotle if
it's a good song you could you know read
somebody else's commentary but I think
if you actually want to make progress
with this because virtue ethics is not
like some other ethical theories where
you just lay the whole theory out now
boom it's done now we just apply it a
lot of virtue ethics make sense
gradually as you progress the different
pieces start to make more sense so I
think it's really good to keep going
back to the text over and over again and
I said it'd still be a bit I mean you
don't have to be a full-time philosopher
in order to live a virtue ethics kind of
kind of existence I think a long myth
that goes being critical about some of
the prevailing ideas about good and bad
right and wrong this doesn't mean that
you have to be a cynic tearing
everything down or you know a skeptic
demanding proof for every single thing
to be critical means to be a good judge
and again that takes some development
over time as well so if somebody for
example says that here's a classic
position well you know this show has the
eyes ratings so it must be the best show
since not just most popular but there
must be something morally good about it
that's pretty questionable right that's
something that you'd one of the good
night mostly always there that's a
that's a kind of crush
something you don't necessarily argue
but you should always like think about
so those are those are ways in which we
would gradually make key ideas of virtue
ethics ro our possession something that
we hold on to in our heads or in our
heart our soul models are also very very
important for virtue ethics to one of
the things that I always thought most
attractive about virtue ethics is the
focus on character of the person rather
than just their individual one time the
act you know at this point at that point
looking at a person over all the time
kind of a person are how do they display
this how do other people view them so I
think whatever you hear people throwing
around terms that describe qualities or
traits of character and saying that
somebody is good or bad because of those
I think you want to think about that I
think you want to stop and see if you
can compare it to some of these key
ideas that you've gotten through study
and I think you want to sort of start
disentangling who's a good judge about
this and it was kind of a sloppy judge
about this or who has a clear conception
would say what integrity consistent and
who just likes throwing around the word
but also look to see when people are
making judgments if they judge the same
way about similar cases a lot of people
like to use language of good or bad
traits as a kind of reward and
punishment system so people that they
like the final suites are good traits in
that until those people cross because
yeah those traits to begin with and then
suddenly they're bad guys now we'll find
all sorts of bad things to say about you
know if you find people like that i'm
going to bet there's some people like
that in your life where do you find
yourself doing this sort of thing that's
not going to be very compatible with a
virtue ethics way of thinking about this
on the other hand if you find people
that can tell you why they say that this
person has integrity or lies if that
person is fundamentally dishonest and
their explanations make good sense you
are a lot of those people so think about
the qualities that people mention I
think it's very important to look at
your media consumption and I'm not going
to totally consistent with this myself I
like Charlie Sheen and he's a reprobate
there's something strangely entertaining
and attractive about him for me but
enough virtue ethics perspective he's
not a good guy as a matter of fact he's
clearly a vicious character he even has
himself knowledge about his vicious
character which doesn't actually make it
good I think you want to look at your
media consumption so what sort of TV
shows are you watching what sort of
things are you watching and you know
when to be your internet
youtube what are you what are you
focusing on what kind of movies are you
watching and talking about what kind of
magazines do what kind of lifestyle
today do they push to they push a
lifestyle which is essentially a nest
egg or are they very moralistic but not
in the virtue ethics way you know things
just to make you feel good about being
moral but not really you know oriented
towards that do they put you in the
script where some people that are the
bad guys no matter what and other people
of the good guys that may not be
compatible for genetics so you won't
would get your media consumption think
about your family and your friends and
your work in a couple of ways if you
come from or if you immerse yourself in
environments where people are for the
most part vicious or simply lack
self-control it will be harder for you
to be virtuous it will be harder for you
in a variety of ways you're not going to
have somebody helping you out there
probably actually hostile to you it
shouldn't want to exercise certain
virtues that will we are out you're very
perspective about what traits are good
and what traits are bad and why they are
good either bed might get skewed as a
result as well so i think it's worth
looking at you know your family is and
what kind of
they have your friends we have someone
more control over and what goes on in
your workplace if you're a student that
needs your classmates I don't just mean
following please do it if you have
clients maybe you need to think about
your clients value how you interact with
them they see you pick the people that
you see actually have good qualities
yeah try to spend more time trying to
interact with them try to figure out how
you would emulate them those who have
very bad qualities maybe spend less time
Chrissa and more time figuring out
whether you have anything in common with
them you need to look at so that's a
good segue into self it's the other
nation and I think a lot more could be
said about this so I'm here to resist
the temptation to blather and only touch
about three days one great time to look
at yourself is when you catch yourself
facing a situation of temptation and
what is the situation of temptation is
where you you know that you want to do
this but you really want to do this
instead and you find yourself kind of
way you catch yourself you see yourself
as a quantity kind of internal debate or
conflict or waiver well you know that's
what you want actually look at yourself
why do you feel this by what's going on
why do you see these goods like this if
you know something that is a less of
good why are you being attracted to
sometimes to temptation give me a matter
of you know to two different evils and
you pick one thing that is actually not
the lesser evil because we really want
with this this thing over here so it
doesn't have to always be positive
another thing I would say is you get in
conflict with other people and comic
books can cover a wide range the
shouting matches can be text exchanges
email flurries can be sort of you know
less overt ones gossiping about people
that's a matter of conflict we argue all
different things we didn't accomplish
the ball all over think some of the
personals personal bigger picture stuff
well some of the virtues you have to do
with with how we conduct ourselves when
we're going to conflict those that have
to do the same anger or with temperance
or Aristotle's virtue friendly that's
actually means being able to set down
limits and say two friends I'm not going
to do that bad thing that you want me to
be willing to give them a pink some
people just like to get people pain
that's not a good thing that's a vice so
some some vices and virtues bear
directly how we academics some other
vices and virtues you have to do with
why we get into the conflicts that would
do you know if you are in temperate
person if you're at the crater your
bodily desires you probably will get
into more conflicts in the link event
than somebody who's more self-control so
you made him look at that if you are an
unjust person you probably need to look
at that too because if you're unjust
you're not only going to get into
confidence with other people who are
just you're going to get in conflicts
with other people who are just finally
to tie this together I think when you're
doing self-examination it's not just
enough
individual circumstances or occasions or
incidents you also want to reflect in a
broader way perhaps daily on what it is
that you really think is good but it is
it you really desire what it is that
you're attracted to and think about what
kind of person that that shows you to be
and whether you're happy with being that
kind of person what would it mean what
would it take to change that so that
leads us finally to practice I just have
two things here one thing has to do with
habits Aristotle says and most virtue
ethics follows along this line that we
become virtuous through habituation what
does that mean well first we're not
originally temperate or courageous or
just or self-control with respect to
anger or anything like that and we
somebody that makes us act that way we
force ourselves to act that way or we
choose to act that way perhaps for
external award which is when punish them
something like that and then over time
that becomes part of our character that
becomes our second nature and then after
a while we want to behave that way
that's the natural way for us to behave
and this works that way from virtues and
it works that way for vice is to keep on
acting run justly or boasting about
yourself you will become
just per person or you will become a
bolster and that will become part of
your character be harder to to root out
so you know actually practicing doing
the things you have to do if you have
problems with time management the only
way to fundamentally change that you
know as far as your characters concern
is to actually make yourself exercise
good time management not sure that is
virtually at falling from probably
temperance mr. consent if you find
yourself being stingy and you want to
quit being stingy you got to break
yourself bad habit and you have to
replace it with the new habits we have
to act in a generous wage the other
thing is very often people think of this
in terms of well just got to build a hat
so I can do in kind of unconscious way
no one you have to actually know what
you're doing and you have to choose it
you have to as they often say take
ownership right you have to decide this
for yourself and at a certain point if
you want to become virtuous you don't
want to just do what's in accordance
with virtue we actually want to become
virtuous you have to choose that as a
good for you you have to see that as a
good thing for you and then you have to
pursue it and choosing that would
involve this entire matrix of those
things because these are all different
ways in which you can concretely choose
in your day-to-day life to practice
virtue ethics so not a complete answer
but not bad for 20 minutes